[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In this
video, I'll show you
how you can use Autograph to
write complex, high performance
TensorFlow code
using normal Python.
Autograph is available in
the new TF2 function API,
makes it easy to run TensorFlow
computations in a way
that's efficient and portable.
When you annotate a Python
function with tf.function,
Autograph will automatically
convert its Python code
to TensorFlow graph code.
The code is then
compiled into a graph
and executed when you
call the function.
Let's look at an example.
This simple function calculates
the square of a scalar input
if it's positive.
In TensorFlow 2.0, you don't
have to use tf.cond anymore.
You can just write a
normal if statement,
and Autograph will generate
a tf.cond operation
so that the entire
computation runs as a graph.
This is the generated code
that Autograph writes for you.
Notice that we're writing
true and false functions that
would normally be fed
into a tf.cond statement.
Instead of writing
these, you can simply
use Python if statements.
Let's take a look at a
more complicated example.
This is a bare bones RNN cell.
Note that it contains a
data dependent for loop,
and it also contains a data
independent if statement.
Autograph will only run the
data dependent loop in the graph
and leave the data independent
if statement untouched.
Simply adding a
tf.function as a decorator
still lets you call the function
directly and get results
immediately.
But the function
runs in graph mode.
It prints results.
And we can also time it.
Now, if we remove the
tf.function decorator, which
I've preemptively done here, and
run the function in eager mode,
we get the same results out.
However, it's going to be a
little bit slower because we
won't have coalesced the entire
function into a single tf.graph
op.
We can time both options
with tf.function in Autograph
and without.
You'll note that using
tf.function, which
requires only a single
function decorator,
is significantly faster
than the eager mode version
without tf.function.
[MUSIC PLAYING]